well it looks like Marvel Studios and
Disney really are making some pretty big
changes when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what is going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things Marvel
and MCU Kevin fige the president of
Marvel Studios and Bob Iger the CEO of
Disney of course have come out several
times over the past several months and
talked about how they're going to be
making a change with their Disney plus
content and just a change overall with
the quality of content that they produce
as a whole and it looks like they are
staying true to their word making some
pretty big changes as we have just found
out that it looks like Marvel Studios
has apparently fired the writers for
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and we've already seen a ton
of reactions online right now this comes
as some good news to some fans and some
bad news to some others this also of
course leaves us with the question of
who exactly is going to be the main
riters for Avengers King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars because there was
something that was actually pretty cool
about Jeff lovess writing King Dynasty
and Michael Waldren writing Secret Wars
and we'll break down everything you need
to know including who could possibly
replace them as the new riders in this
video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month only a handful of days
left now so this report is coming from
the very reliable Insider my time to
shine hello who originally tweeted this
out no screenwriters will be hired for
King Dynasty and Secret Wars until the
strikes are over but it should be Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller I'm pretty
sure I'm not the first person to suggest
them and for good reason and across the
spiderverse they handled 280 variations
of Spider-Man 95 of which are unique and
named characters plus the villain the
action scenes character development
humor drama romance and of course the
concept of the Multiverse there perfect
now my time to shine hello tweeting this
implied that Jeff lovess and Michael
Waldren were no longer writing King
Dynasty in secret Wars because her tweet
started off by stating no screenwriters
will be hired for Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars but to follow that up Skyler
Schuler over at the dis insider.com
asked this so are you saying lovess and
walren are off King Dynasty and Secret
Wars in which my time to shine simply
replied with yes so according to The
Insider my time to shine hello Jeff
lovess and Michael Waldren are no long
longer the writers for Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars now some people think this
is good because if you didn't know Jeff
lovess wrote Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and Michael Waldren Along
With Sam Ry wrote Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness so the fans who
didn't like those two movies are
actually pretty excited about this news
however keep in mind Michael Waldren
also wrote Loki season 1 and it was
phenomenal there's also the fact that
Jeff lovess and Michael Waldren are
really good friends which which kind of
helps them when they're going to be
writing a part one and a part two movie
essentially the King Dynasty being part
one and Secret Wars being part two that
would definitely help with continuity
purposes and connectivity the two of
them have been very close for some time
now because they work together on Rick
and Morty where most people agree that
the writing for that is pretty dang good
plus they've already written a few
things for the MCU so they have a pretty
good grasp on where things are going
right now plus King Dynasty and Secret
Wars are going to be huge connected
films not solo films that aren't really
connected to anything plus not to
mention when they wrote for Rick and
Morty they actually dealt with a
Multiverse so they do have experience
but it doesn't really matter now because
if this report is true they're off it
now they could have quit on their own
but what most likely happened is that
Marvel Studios and Disney are trying to
shake things up a little bit and let
them go they looked at the success that
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania had
and the success that Multiverse of
Madness had and they said well we want
it to be better even though there are a
lot of people out there who enjoyed both
those films Marvel Studios still felt it
necessary to make some changes to try
and improve the quality of the content
that they're putting out especially when
it comes to the two biggest movies of
the Multiverse Saga the two Avengers
films and Secret Wars are supposed to be
the biggest Avengers movie ever so it
looks like they are sticking true to
their word to try and increase the
quality of things now as far as who
could replace them what The Insider my
time to shine hello stated is actually a
pretty great idea she stated that Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller should be
the ones to write these films now if you
don't know the names they wrote and they
produced Spider-Man across the
spiderverse which was a massive success
recently and Phil Lord wrote the first
spider-verse film Spider-Man into the
spiderverse while Christopher Miller
didn't write the first one he did help
produce it as well and most of the
fandom shares pretty much the same
opinion about these films they're
awesome but what my time to shine hello
stated is also very very correct they
were able to handle 280 Vari ation of
Spider-Man and 95 of which are very
unique and none of them are really the
same and they really did handle so many
different aspects of this movie
extremely well the action the romance
the character development humor it was
all done incredibly well but the most
important part is they handled the
concept of the Multiverse kind of better
than we've ever really seen it done plus
we know that in secret Wars there's
going to be a lot of cameos the
Multiverse is going to be falling into
destruction en cursion are going to be
happening universes are going to be
colliding we're going to see a lot of
variants of a lot of different
characters that is what secret Wars is
going to be about we've already started
to see that in Multiverse of Madness and
we're going to really see that in
Deadpool 3 and in theory secret War
should be even bigger I mean we've heard
rumors that Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield are going to be returning Hugh
Jackman is going to be sticking around
until Avengers Secret Wars the original
X-Men will be there as well we could
also see variants such as Tom Cruz's
Iron Man finally Superior Iron Man let's
also not forget the rumors that Captain
America Chris Evans could return to play
him and Robert Downey Jr could return as
Iron Man and side note I would actually
really love to see Robert Downey Jr play
a variant of Steve Rogers and Chris
Evans play a variant of Tony Stark but
the point is Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller could handle all of these
different cameos because they have
already done a project that has an
extreme amount of different variants of
character and they did it on different
scales they have Miles Morales and then
you have Gwen Stacy from a different
Universe Spider-Man 29 99 from a
different Universe spider punk you have
all of these main characters from
different universes but then you had the
spider Hub which had tons of different
Spider-Man from tons of different
universes all handled extremely well and
remember we're still talking about story
we're talking about screenwriting the
writers for these projects and I would
assume that Marvel Studios would
probably hire both of them as a team to
direct both films not each of them
separately and it honestly makes sense
for the same writer or writers to write
both of the films it's just like for
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
endgame they had Christopher Marcus and
Steven mcely write both of them the same
thing goes for the directors the Russa
Brothers directed both Infinity war and
then endgame and this worked extremely
well because they were essentially
writing one big story the same thing
goes for King Dynasty and Secret Wars
they are basically a part one and a part
two they are the same story so you
probably want the same writers to write
both of them and since they have done
such a great job with the into the
spiderverse franchise so far they might
be our best BET right now unfortunately
nothing official can happen of course
until after the strikes negotiations
can't even happen right now but of
course when the strikes are over they
can talk and hopefully they'll get these
two or some other incredibly talented
writers as well fingers crossed and
we'll have new writers for Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars if we hear anything
about any updates in regards to this
we'll be sure to let you know so be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos please let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below would you like for Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller to be the writers of
these two films or do you think another
writer or writers would be better let us
know all your thoughts in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
woof